[Music]
you know i had an idea i thought while i
was in new york it might be fun
to visit some of the people that i used
to work with
but i wanted to do it
in a way that wouldn't be awkward for
anybody
so i went out and i got a disguise
i really did this take a look
first i want to disguise myself a little
bit
so i think i'll uh
i'll go with the san diego chargers fan
because i'm not a san diego chargers fan
that should throw people off the trail
i asked for realistic mustaches
this is the first one
that i pulled out
and it looks like a boomerang
puts on a male hormone
how does that look
gonna look like a hipster
pedophile who's at san diego
that's what i look like
unibomber let's do this
go chargers
working on my character
my name is charles lafontaine
but my friends call me chuck
i think i'm fairly well disguised
and coming up a show a lot of people
love to talk about amc's breaking bad
mr walker i've got a check of the
weather
you can check your weather any time of
the day
[Applause]
star of breaking bad
[Applause]